le salon de l'agriculture est déjà bien
Tola et Louvre ce samedi sur le site
Paris Expo Porte de Versailles et le
département des Yvelines y sera bien
représenté second territoire agricole
d'Île-de-France les producteurs sont au
rendez-vous toute cette semaine nous
recevrons dans le 7 8 un artisan ou un
éleveur du territoire ce soir focus sur
les ruchers de l'espoir avec Raphaël
Berardino alors vous avez fait le choix
d'une apiculture extensive qui préserve
la santé de l'abeille plutôt qu'une
apiculture intensive alors est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire plus comment
est-ce que vous procédez concrètement
déjà en apiculture intensive vous avez
souvent vous déplacer les ruches vous
avez besoin de les déplacer toujours de
les mettre au maximum en fait de ce
qu'elles sont capables de produire
souvent il faut les nourrir il faut les
déplacer enfin il y a beaucoup
d'activités autour de autour de ça pour
qu'elle produise au maximum
et l'extensif on va les laisser vivre en
fait elle va produire moins il en faut
évidemment plus si on veut on veut
arriver à en vivre mais par contre on
intervient le moins possible de façon à
ce qu'elle peut vivre toute seule en
fait alors on n'est plus dans une
situation où on pouvait laisser les
abeilles vivre sans rien faire voilà ça
c'est plus possible c'était vrai
peut-être il y a 50 ans mais c'est plus
vraiment
pour plein de raisons mais voilà les
pesticides les maladies
levarois enfin tout un tas de facteurs
qui font qu'on si on abandonne les
ruches
c'est d'ailleurs un peu la problématique
qu'on peut avoir aussi un peu dans les
Yvelines c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de
gens qui ont des abeilles mais qui s'en
occupent pas ou pas suffisamment ça veut
pas dire qu'on s'en occupe pas
l'extensif ça veut dire que on les
laisse faire quand on peut et puis quand
on doit intervenir on intervient mais
ainsi une espèce c'est l'abeille noire
alors l'abeille noire c'est notre
abeille endémique donc local
je suis à côté et j'ai une partie de mes
ruches qui sont dans le conservatoire de
la baignoire à Bugnon donc le canif ça
ça en fait l'objectif en fait
effectivement de protéger cet abeille
qui en fait se trouve être
en danger assez fortement lié à toutes
les importations en fait de différentes
de différentes variétés qui viennent un
peu de partout et qui sont pas forcément
adaptés à notre à notre environnement à
notre à notre climat etc et donc
l'hybridation va faire que on perd en
fait des caractéristiques génétiques de
notre abeille et qui vont venir se
mélanger avec d'autres avec d'autres
abeilles et qui au final vont dégrader
en fait
la résistance en fait de ces abeilles
extensive
autour de autour de Galluis un petit peu
plus côté Rambouillet
et j'en ai 300 répartis par des ruchers
maximum de vin de vins colonies
alors c'est pas tellement une question
de goût en fait alors je moi je récolte
par rucher et chaque en fait chaque
chaque pot a le nom de son du rucher qui
a été produit donc vous pouvez avoir des
écarts entre différents ruchers qui sont
même très proches parce que à 1 km près
on peut avoir des fleurs qui sont qui
sont assez différentes
et puis après vous pouvez avoir des
miels qui sont assez proches d'une
distance plus éloignée c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment lié à l'environnement de
lier de autour qui se trouve autour du
rucher les abeilles peuvent aller
environ à 3 km autour mais elles vont
vraiment récolter dans le kilomètre
autour du autour du rocher
je faisais quoi comme différents types
de miel alors en fait je propose ce qui
arrive et pas c'est pas moi qui décide
en fait je fais deux récoltes par an une
au printemps une en été je peux avoir du
c'est généralement du multifloral en
fait je vais pas chercher à faire du
monofloral ce qui est voilà quand on
fait de l'intensif on peut chercher à
faire du multifloral on va un endroit où
il y a tel type de fleur et on va
récolter cette fleur là moi je fais que
deux récoltes par an une au printemps et
une en été si si ça peut c'est pas
toujours le cas et après suivant
l'endroit je vais avoir je sais pas en
été je vais avoir de l'acacia qui va
être mélangé avec du tilleul je vais
avoir du châtaignier enfin voilà ça va
se mélanger des fois j'ai du
spécifiquement une fleur mais c'est
parce que les autres n'ont pas donné
c'est plutôt ça et vous avez une
technique de récolte particulière ou
pour que ça se passe suffisamment
à peu près pareil on travaille de la
même façon quand on intensif la
différence moi c'est que je vais pas
chauffer du tout le miel que ce soit à
l'extraction
ou que ce soit la mise en pot parce que
souvent en fait la problématique c'est
qu'on met le miel mais le miel en fût et
pour après derrière le mettre en pause
il va falloir le chauffer puisqu'il aura
cristallisé donc moi je le mets en pot
directement à la récolte ce qui fait que
de garder ses bienfaits il garde ses
bienfaits voilà tout à fait il est pas
chauffé à chaque fois vous chauffez un
peu le miel
alors en règle générale voilà si on
dépasse 40 dès qu'on dépasse 40 degrés
on va perdre à la fois en bienfaits et à
la fois en qualité au niveau du goût on
va perdre aussi une partie des
la qualité du miel voilà il y a beaucoup
d'apiculteurs qui rencontrent des
difficultés face aux dérèglements
climatique c'est aussi votre cas oui
genre je rencontre bien sûr vous voyez
là on est au mois de février et elle
devrait être vraiment elle devrait être
en hivernage elle devrait plus bouger
elle devrait en grappe et ne plus bouger
et elles sont dehors là donc elles sont
en train de récolter du pollen donc si
la saison reste douce comme ça je dirais
que ça et puis si on se reprend comme il
y a deux ans 15 jours où il a fait -8 et
bien derrière c'est c'est une éca tombe
parce que elles sont là elles sont
vraiment reparties et s'il fait vraiment
froid comme ça là on peut avoir des
pères très très lourdes à votre niveau
vous n'êtes pas inquiet justement par
rapport à si mais après voilà enfin soit
on fait pas enfin c'est vraiment un
métier où il faut accepter les aléas
sinon sinon on travaille pas on essaie
moi j'essaie de faire le maximum pour
que voilà elles est suffisamment de
nourriture pour passer l'hiver qu'elle
soit que tout va bien de sélectionner au
mieux de garder les meilleurs souches
pour que ça puisse s'appuie sanctionner
maintenant voilà on a une part d'Alea ça
peut aller pendant l'hiver on peut
perdre quand tout va bien on perd 5 10%
et quand ça va mal voilà j'ai déjà perdu
80% sur une sur une année donc là il
faut l'accepter ça sinon vous
plus d'apiculture et c'est quoi pour
vous une bonne année bonne année moi qui
perd où je perds années 15-20%, ça va
c'est raisonnable et bien merci beaucoup
notre invitation je vous souhaite un bon
salon de l'agriculture ce dernier se
tiendra du samedi 25 février au 5 mars à
Porte de Versailles demain nous
recevrons la fermeture qui sera
également présente au salon de
l'agriculture